The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So today
we're going to take
a little bit of a lightning
tour through some basic topics
on chemical enzyme kinetics,
before thinking a little bit
about some, what you might
call, simple input-output
relationships, in terms
of gene expression.
I've got separation
of time scale,
and also this basic notion
that for a stable protein
there's a natural
time scale over which
the concentration
will go up or down,
and that's dictated by
the cell generation time.
At the end, we'll then talk
about different ways you get
this thing of ultrasensitivity.
So, how is it that
you can make it
so that a small change in
the input concentration,
say the concentration of
a transcription factor,
might be able to lead to a
large change in the output,
or the gene expression
of its target?
We'll talk about
how you can have,
for example, cooperative
binding at the promoter,
or you can have multimerization,
kind of leads to similar things
here.
But also, we're going
to talk about this idea
of molecular titration.
So if you have another protein
that acts as kind of a sponge,
then this connect can
lead to a similar effect.
And this is indeed observed
in various natural contexts.
So this is motivated by a work
by Nick Buchler, B-U-C-H-L-E-R.
Turns out I was down
at Princeton, no sorry,
I was out at Duke yesterday, and
so I got to hang out with Nick
and talk about this work.
I had previously told him
that in my first lecture
in the systems
biology class, we like
to discuss this molecular
titration effect.
He was instrumental in
elucidating how it worked.
All right so let's go
ahead and get started.
So hopefully you all
have these cards.
We're going to start out
with some simple questions,
just to make sure
that you know how
to use the complicated
devices that
are sitting in front of you.
OK?
So what we want
to do is to start
by thinking about a situation
where you have two molecules.
We're going to
call them E and S,
and of course, you can imagine
what these might possibly stand
for in one context or another.
There are two rates
here that are describing
the rate that these molecules,
E and S, find each other, Kf.
And Kr is defining the rate
at which this complex is
going to fall apart.
So there's this
forward rate that
is sum Kf, times
concentration of E,
times the
concentration of S. Now
I'd say for the first
part of this lecture,
we will indeed use the chemistry
convention of concentrations
here, although we will quickly
get tired of these brackets
and we'll just start
writing the letters.
And hopefully it is self
evident in the context
that I'm referring to
a concentration rather
than something else, but if
you're ever confused, please
ask.
So this is forward rate,
and then the reverse rate
is something similar.
So we have this Kr.
Now this is just
the concentration
of the complex ES.
Many of you have spent
a lot of time thinking
about how we often
define things.
This Kd, dissociation
constant, is defined
as the ratio Kr over Kf.
Now, just so we can practice
using our cards, what
we're going to ask first is what
the units of this Kd thing is.
Now, in general, when
I ask such a question,
I will give you some
A, B, C, D options.
You can start thinking
even before I write down
the options.
Yes?
I'll encourage you
to think before I
start writing down options.
So it's either dimensionless,
units of concentration,
1 over concentration,
1 over time,
and I will often include at
the bottom something that
simply is, don't know.
And that is if you're
really confused
about what I'm
talking about, then
feel free to just flash me
that, and that at least tells me
that I'm gibbering nonsense.
So there's going to be a
very strict set of rules
for how we do these
flash cards, all right?
You don't get to vote
before I tell you to vote.
You have to keep on thinking.
If you think you know
the right answer,
check limits, just do whatever
it is to keep on thinking.
And then we vote simultaneously.
That way, it builds up the
tension, everyone gets excited,
and then you vote.
It also provides
me an opportunity
to make sure that I can see
that everybody's participating.
So if you don't vote, then
you have the opportunity
to tell the group what you think
the answer should be and why.
And the cards
they're both colored,
and they have letters on there,
so the letters correspond
to the answer.
We're all on top of this?
Have you had a chance to think?
Or has my talking bothered you?
Both.
OK.
So what we do is I'm going to
ask, do you need more time?
If you need more time, just
nod or something like that,
and if more than a few people
nod, I'll give you more time.
But you guys are
totally all right.
OK let's see how we are.
So then I'll say,
OK, we're ready.
And then we're going to go
three, two, one, and then
I want a vote by your chest.
You don't need to
display it to the group.
It's just here, and then
tell me what you think.
All right, ready.
Three, two, one.
Broadly, people know
how to use the cards.
And there's a clear
majority of the group,
although it's not 100%, that
are saying that this thing is
a concentration.
I'd say that if the group
is maybe between 25,
75% correct on these
sorts of things,
then I will often have you
pair off in, well, in pairs.
And the goal there
would be to try
to convince your neighbor
that you're right.
In this case we're
a bit above 75%,
so I've already indicated
what the answer is.
Can somebody just quickly say,
why is this a concentration?
Maybe in the back.
AUDIENCE: So, we know
that both rates need
to have the same dimensions--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, and what are
the dimensions of these rates?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So, there are actually different
conventions, in principle,
but we will often be
working in numbers
in most of this
class, in which case
it would actually
just be a 1 over time.
But depending on whether
you're doing chemistry-- So
the numerators may be
ambiguous, depending,
but the important thing is that
they're definitely the same.
These are definitely
going to be the same.
But it is true that in an
awful lot of this class,
we're going to be
thinking about numbers
rather than the concentrations.
Because, for a lot
of the class we'll
be thinking about finite
number fluctuations
of stochastic dynamics, in which
case, concentration, who knows
what's going to happen?
But these have to have
the same units, right?
And the important thing here
is if you look at the right,
you see this guy has an
extra concentration up here.
So, I think this is, on the
one hand, a trivial point,
but it's just really
easy to forget about
as you move forward.
Because these things, they
look awfully similar, right?
There's a K, little
subscript something, right?
So just be careful about
this kind of thing.
Are there any questions
about what I've said so far?
So in these cases.
I think that it's
really very useful
to try to get some intuition
for what's going on.
These are all just
definitions, but you
want to ask, well, what
happens if concentrations
of various things move around?
What we want to think
about is just the fraction.
And the reason we call this
E is because, for now, we
might be calling this an enzyme
and, over here, a substrate,
something that the
enzyme is acting on.
But we'll see that,
in many cases,
we might be thinking about
one of these as being,
let's say, the piece
of DNA, and then
this is not even the substrate.
Then maybe this is the
RNA polymerase that
will lead to transcription.
So in various contexts, we'll
think about these things having
different molecular identities.
But for now, E and S,
possibly enzyme substrate.
So the question is, if
for now we just think,
these are just two
molecules of whatever sort,
at some concentration, and
we just want to make sure
that we are on top
of what's going
to happen if the
concentrations of each
of these molecular
components goes
either to 0 or to infinity.
I think that before you
do any math in life,
it's good to just think
about these sorts of limits,
because it helps to make sure
that your intuition is correct.
In many, many cases, if
you think about the problem
before you do any math, then
when you go do the math,
you'll get some solution.
You can check to see
whether your solution is
consistent with what
your intuition said.
And if they disagree
it means you
have to update either your
intuition, or the solution,
or maybe both.
It's possible.
But at least one of
them has to be updated,
and that's a way of both getting
better scores on your exams,
but also improving your
scientific intuition.
So, in particular, we just
want to do some limits.
We'll think in the
context, for example,
if the total concentration--
your adding of the small S--
if it goes to zero,
what we're going
to try to get intuition about
is this fraction of E-bound.
It might be the enzyme.
So the fraction of
this thing bound,
it's defined by the
concentration of the complex,
divided by the
concentration of the enzyme,
plus the concentration of
the enzyme in the complex,
assuming that this is the only
two places that the enzyme can
be located.
Now, these three arrows, that,
in general, means a definition.
So the question is,
if we come here,
what happens to the fraction
of this enzyme that's bound?
And, again, can't be
determined-- which
is different from don't know.
And we're going to just
do a few different limits
so we want to maybe go
through these quickly.
I'll give you 10 seconds
to prepare your card.
All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
So we're pretty good.
So I'd say a majority,
at least, of the group
is saying that in this case, the
fraction bound should go to 0.
Intuitively, why should that be?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: A little louder.
AUDIENCE: You have
nothing to bind.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, right.
So if there's no
S around at all,
then you shouldn't have
much of this complex, right?
But you still have some enzymes.
This thing should go to 0,
and that kind of makes sense.
And, similarly, if you add a
lot, a lot of this substrate?
I'll give you eight seconds.
AUDIENCE: So, you're moving
the substrate [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, so S
total, this is the total.
This is if you have
a test tube, and this
is the amount of this sugar
that you add in there.
So S total, then, is
the sum of that and S.
Do you need more time?
Ready.
Three, two, one.
So we have maybe an island
of people that disagree.
At least a majority are
saying, in this case,
it should have to go to 1.
Of course, this is
a limit and a limit.
It's always going to be between
0 and 1, but in the limit,
it does go to 1.
So if you just add so
much of the substrate
then you should be able
to saturate that binding
and drive all of that
enzyme into the bound state.
So this one is actually, maybe,
a little bit more subtle.
So what if we take this limit?
I'm going to give you 20
seconds to think about it, just
because it's roughly three
times as hard as the last one.
Do you need more time?
Or do you think that you have
something you believe in,
that you're willing to
turn to your neighbor
and-- Let's see where we are.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
All right, so this is good.
So we have a fair
distribution, and this is one
that reasonable people might
be able to argue about.
It's worth having the argument.
Give yourself 30 seconds,
turn your neighbor,
preferably a neighbor
that disagrees with you,
and tell them why you
said what you said.
If in a pair, you've
already convinced
each other of something,
then go ahead and look around
to see if there's another
pair that has maybe
settled on a different answer.
I think that you guys are still
kind of passionately arguing,
but maybe we'll go
ahead and convene,
and try to get a sense of--
I think, from the sound of it
at least, there's some
disagreement about the way
to think about this.
In general, if you
want to volunteer
an opinion or an explanation,
what I like to do is,
I like to tell the group
what your neighbor thought.
So go ahead, anybody, it
could be a neighbor in quotes.
Anybody want to volunteer
one possible explanation
of how to think about this?
AUDIENCE: Well, what
my neighbors thought
was if E total is
defined as E plus ES,
then as E total goes to 0,
then this goes to 0 over 0
at some vague, unclear--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
although, right.
So you're saying, maybe
it's all going to 0,
and then this is
just philosophy.
Not that I'm putting words
in your neighbor's mouth.
So there's a sense in which this
is true, but mathematically,
and actually also physically,
there are well-defined ways
of taking such a limit, right?
So if you get 0 over 0, then
you can use L'Hopital's Rule,
which we'll have the
opportunity to pull out sometime
within the class.
Of course, the most difficult
part of L'Hopital's Rule
is knowing how to spell it.
So that's one answer,
the mathematical answer,
that you should be able to just
take this limit and so forth.
But I think there is another
physical answer, which is
that this could happen, right?
And something is
going to occur, right?
You could, in
principle, measure.
And even if you just had
a single enzyme there,
this Fb would be the fraction of
time that that enzyme is bound.
So this is a well-defined
experimental question
and the answer should arise
from these interactions.
But then how do we edit
it-- what does it all mean?
How do we figure out the answer?
What's another
possible view on this?
Maybe in the back.
AUDIENCE: My neighbor
thought that,
if there's a non-zero
concentration of S,
and the concentration
of E goes to 0,
then all E will be bound
[? at some point ?].
PROFESSOR: This is
interesting, right?
So, if there's a finite
concentration of S,
if E goes to 0, then
you say well there's
plenty of S to go around, so
I should always get bound.
Is that what the neighbor--
that's another option.
So, so far, we've
had an argument
for can't be determined,
it's philosophy.
We've had an argument for 1.
Other possibilities?
This is an interesting
question, because depending
on how you think about it,
you can convince yourself
that it's anything, right?
Other possible answers?
No.
AUDIENCE: So, I don't
hear the good answer.
I said E because, when
there isn't very much E,
then it's true that a lot of
people go into yes, but yeah.
I don't know what to say.
PROFESSOR: Now, that's OK.
Another take on that
answer, or a different one?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
If I had to complete
that answer,
maybe something like,
but there still might not
be a total large
concentration of either,
so there might still be
a decent chance for E
to be around for a while
without encountering some of S.
AUDIENCE 2: So the
forward reaction rate
will also go to 0.
Even though S is very large,
the forward reaction rate
will also go to 0, as the
concentration [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: By the
forward rate, it's
not necessarily a
variable. it's just
that it depends on the substrate
concentration in this case.
Other takes on it?
This is interesting.
So I'm going to argue that the
most reasonable way to view
this would give you--
as long as there
is some finite concentration
of that substrate around,
and I think that there's a very
well-defined sense in which
it's going to go to
some finite fraction.
And I think that when
you're thinking about this
in the context of molecular
kinetics, the chemistry of you,
it still is all
well-defined, but the way
that I think that I get the
most clear intuition is just
to imagine myself as being that
one and only enzyme in the test
tube.
Now there's going to
be some rate that I
bind to the substrates, right?
And what's going to
determine that rate?
AUDIENCE: The concentration
of the substrate?
PROFESSOR: The concentration
of substrate, right.
So if I double the
substrate concentration,
what should that do to
the rate of me binding?
It should double it, yeah.
And then of course
there's always
this Kf somewhere in there,
and some units, right?
But there's going to be
some rate that I bind.
And then when I bind again?
Now I'm just an
enzyme substrate.
Now, instead thinking about
this in the context of chemical
kinetics, I can just
think about this
from the standpoint of an
individual molecule, where
I'm a complex, S-bound,
and there's some rate
that I fall apart.
And it's just the balance
of those two rates
of finding a substrate
and falling part
that's going to lead
to this fraction bound.
AUDIENCE: Taking what
you just explained,
couldn't you think about it
as E always either 0 or 1,
because when you're--
PROFESSOR: Yeah
AUDIENCE: --in the case of
having one [? and the same-- ?]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So, if you'd like, we could
put an average sign here,
to say an average over time.
Because in many, many cases,
what we're really interested in
is the fraction of time that,
say, the promoter is bound,
or the enzyme is
bound, or whatnot.
And if you have many,
many, many molecules, then
at any moment in time, the
average is the time average.
But once you're down
to a single molecule,
then you really want
to take a time average.
We'll revisit this in just
a moment using the math,
but what's interesting is the
math also can mislead you.
Other questions?
If somebody wants
to argue forcefully
what their neighbor
said was right,
then I'm happy to-- we will come
back to this in a little bit.
If I want to do the
fourth possibility, which
is the total concentration
of the enzyme,
it's going to go to infinity.
I'll give you, again, eight
seconds to think and then
get your card ready.
Are you ready?
Three, two, one.
OK.
So we actually have a fair
amount of disagreement,
between As and Bs it seems.
Go ahead and, again,
turn to your neighbor,
but maybe find somebody
that disagrees with you.
Sometimes there are
pockets of people that
agree one way or the other.
So try to find each other.
Yeah, I know.
I understand.
You can try to figure out the
expression for the fraction
bound, and how that behaves.
And that's actually kind
of weird as well, frankly.
Why don't we go ahead and
reconvene, just so I can see.
And maybe, let's go
ahead and re-vote,
so I can see if
anybody convinced
anybody of anything else.
Ready.
Three, two, one.
So it seems like now there's
pretty good agreement.
The answer to this
is going to be
A. There were a fair number
of people that said B before.
So here comes our curvy lines.
And so the idea here
is that in the limit
of the enzyme concentration
going to infinity,
in that limit the fraction
bound has to go to 0,
because you just don't
have any substrate to bind.
And even if all the
substrate's bound-- and indeed
in this limit, what
fraction of the substrate
ends up being bound?
AUDIENCE: All of it.
PROFESSOR: All of it, right.
So then, indeed,
the fraction bound
is just going to be
the concentration
of the substrate divided by the
concentration of the enzyme.
In the limit of
the concentration
of the enzyme going to
infinity, then the fraction
of the enzyme bound
is going to go to 0.
You're unhappy.
AUDIENCE: I think having made
an extremely eloquent argument,
number 3 for B, I actually
think that that answer is wrong.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So this one, right?
Yes, I mean, you
had convinced me.
AUDIENCE: So if you take
E total to 0 at fixed S--
PROFESSOR: Fixed S, yes.
AUDIENCE: --then the
reaction rate is--
PROFESSOR: You have to take
the limits carefully, I think.
AUDIENCE: --is a ratio
of the forward propensity
and the backwards propensity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think that the clearest
way to think about it
is as just that single enzyme.
Because, it's certainly going
to have some rate of binding,
and then once it's
bound it's going
to have some rate
of falling apart.
And that ratio is not a
function of whether there's
one enzyme-- I mean, that
ratio is well-defined.
The time average
of the probability
of that enzyme being
bound is, indeed,
a well-defined quantity.
AUDIENCE: So can Ethan say
D and it depends on the Kd?
PROFESSOR: Well, people
always like to argue Ds.
We can write down what the
expression is, actually, now.
And then you can decide whether
you think D is justified.
We can also just
try to figure out,
what's the equilibrium
of this thing?
So the change in the
complex concentration
as a function of
time is just going
to be the rate of creation
minus the rate of destruction.
So there's just going
to be this K forward,
ES-- oh sorry, these
brackets are awful-- Kr, ES.
And we just want to
set this equal to 0,
if we want to figure out what
the equilibrium there is.
And in one line, you can find
that the fraction bound can
be written as a concentration
of the substrate here,
divided by Kd, plus S. Is
this correct from standpoint
of units?
So there's something that
you might find troubling
about this expression, though.
Is anybody troubled by it?
AUDIENCE: But it equals 0.
PROFESSOR: You could say,
what if E total is 0?
I'd say that if E total
is actually zero, now
I think that's an
ill-defined quantity.
So, at some point, I'll side
with the philosophers here.
But if there is an enzyme to
talk about fraction bound,
then-- So it's related
to this, but it's--
AUDIENCE: But whenever you
have [INAUDIBLE] E [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So we've already discussed
from our intuition
that as E total
goes to infinity,
then the fraction bound
is supposed to go what?
To 0, we decided, right?
And does this
expression do that?
AUDIENCE: Well this
is S, not S total.
PROFESSOR: Yes!
So this is S, not S total.
And once again, really
easy to screw this up.
Because, in many contexts, S
and S total are the same thing.
Especially, in context
of enzyme kinetics,
it's often the case that the
concentration enzyme is really
rather low, and then the
substrate concentration
is huge, so then S and
S total we can really
treat as being interchangeable.
But here, in the general
context, we can't.
And this concentration
of S, this thing
is a function of the
concentration of the enzyme.
So this guy here,
it's a function
of the total amount
of substrate you have
and also E total, and
for that matter, Kd.
So really this thing
is a true statement,
but it's very misleading
if you're not keeping track
of what these things mean.
Because, this thing is very
simple, except for that
it's really actually complicated
because S section depends
on everything right?
Now there's one
context in which you
can be safe in assuming that
S and S total are the same,
and that's in the limit of, for
example, E total going to 0.
So if you just have 1
enzyme, then this expression
is, essentially, always valid.
Every now and then,
you might be using up
one of your substrate
molecules, occasionally.
Right?
But it's pretty safe to say
that in the limit of E total
going 0, when it's just in
the limit of one enzyme,
then it's really just
described by a curve that
looks like this.
And this curve is something
that you see over, and over,
and over again.
And this is the
fundamental reason
that Michaelis Menten kinetics
looks the way it does.
But this is going to
be very useful for us
because, in many contexts
that we're interested in,
we want to think
about, for example,
the rate expression
of some gene.
And what we want to know
about is the fraction of time
that it's going to be bound by,
say, a transcription factor.
So then, in the
simplest case, we
get an input-output relationship
that is just given by this.
Because, there's just one,
or few copies, of that DNA,
so it doesn't really sequester
the transcription factor
that's going to be binding it.
Do you guys understand
why this is weird?
A thing you have
to be careful of?
And more generally,
I strongly recommend
that, in all of these
sorts of problems,
it's good to just
plot some things.
For example, the
fraction bound is
a function of if you vary
the substrate concentration.
Because, often you think that
you know what's going on,
and then when you just go and
sit down to draw some curve,
just get your
intuition, you realize
you don't know where it starts,
you don't where it ends,
you don't know what
it does in between.
It's embarrassing,
but it's only when
you sit down and try to do
something like that that you
realize that it's not obvious.
So just, for example, it's
useful to imagine a situation,
just between a
similar E and S, where
we, for the sake
of argument, say
that S total is around this Kd.
Now what we want to do is
ask, what's the fraction
bound as a function of E total?
So we're going to
fix total substrate,
vary the enzyme concentration.
So we already know what
the limit here should be.
We go to infinity,
what should this go to?
0.
We know that eventually
it should go to 0,
and we already figured that
out for any finite substrate
concentration.
Incidentally, on
many of the exams,
I will ask for plots
of curves like this.
So basically you
want to indicate
where it goes on one
end, where it starts--
and where is it going to start
in the limit of E total going
to 0?
Half.
Then it's actually
accurately described by that.
So we start here.
This is 1.
So we start at 1/2.
And it's going to have to go
in between those two, right?
So what's the characteristic
concentration here
where something-- where
it's changing a lot?
AUDIENCE: Kd?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Kd.
Kd's actually the only
concentration in the problem.
So that means that's
what sets scale.
And I don't know, Kd,
exactly where it should
be, but something in there.
So in these sorts
of situations, you
want to get the limits and
what is it that sets the scale?
If there's a peak,
is where is it?
I encourage for a
few toy examples,
just draw some of these things.
It's a fun way to spend
a Saturday afternoon.
Are there any questions
about what we've said so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What's the Fb
when E total equals Kd?
PROFESSOR: So the
question is, what
is the fraction of the
enzyme that's bound
when E total is equal to Kd?
I think we could figure it
out, but it might actually
be a little bit of math.
Let me see.
I would have to think
about it, but it's
going to be around a third or
a fifth, somewhere in there.
If somebody gets bored
with what I'm saying,
they can do the calculation
and report to us
at the end of class.
So what we've just done,
it feels like a lot of time
to spend on two molecules
binding to each other,
but I think that it's
good to just make sure
that you're comfortable with
the simplest kind of process
before you start thinking
about things that
are super complicated, for
example, Michaelis Menten
kinetics.
So it's not super complicated.
E plus S. So now it's
the same thing here,
where we have K forward, K
reverse, to this complex.
But here, at some rate,
Kcat, enzyme does something,
turns it into a product.
Now this is a model of
how an enzyme works.
It is not a perfect description
of reality in any given case,
or in general.
What's the most obvious
possible point of concern?
AUDIENCE: There's
no way to go back
PROFESSOR: No way to go
back, well that's OK.
What's that matter with that?
AUDIENCE: Well,
sometimes there is.
PROFESSOR: Well
OK.
I'd say the problem
is, in some ways,
more fundamental than
just, sometimes there is.
Right?
It's true that sometimes--
but sometimes lots of things
happen.
Sometimes the enzyme
binds 2 substrates.
On any specific case,
there are many ways
that this thing can
fail, but there's
a more fundamental sense
which is a problem.
AUDIENCE: The rate at which it
produces the-- P doesn't depend
on any other small molecules.
It depends on other
concentrations--
PROFESSOR: OK, right.
So what Sam is saying
is, well this Kcat
is not a function
of other things.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: It's true, and
in many cases in might,
but there's a real sense in
which this thing is failing
fundamentally for any enzyme.
And I just want to make
sure that we're all--
AUDIENCE: Dissociation of P.
PROFESSOR: Dissociation
of P, and what--
AUDIENCE: From the enzyme.
PROFESSOR: So, you don't
like the dissociation?
AUDIENCE: We don't have
an association there.
You're assuming that
the Kf of disocciation--
PROFESSOR: Oh, right.
Although, I could argue, Kcat
is some kind of bulk parameter
that tells you about the
rate of breaking some bond
and dissociating.
And it's just a simple model.
We don't want to
ask too much of it.
AUDIENCE: K reverse is huge.
PROFESSOR: K reverse is huge?
Well, I haven't told
you what K reverse is.
So, it's not huge.
I mean, it could be.
So far we haven't said
anything about what it is.
What are the fundamental
properties of an enzyme?
Or a catalyst, for that matter?
When you go home
for Thanksgiving,
your grandmother asks
you, honey, tell me,
what's a catalyst?
AUDIENCE: It's doesn't get
used during the reaction.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't get
used up during the reaction.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't get
used up in the reaction.
OK, perfect, not used up.
And does this
model violate that?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: So all right.
Grandma's happy.
AUDIENCE: You can deactivate
or activate these catalysts?
I don't know.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
it's true, there's
some enzymes you can
activate, deactivate.
How you deactivate a protein
enzyme, if you wanted to?
AUDIENCE: Denature.
PROFESSOR: You could denature
it from heat or salt.
But that's maybe not one
of the most fundamental.
AUDIENCE: You should have a rate
from S to P without the enzyme.
PROFESSOR: Right so maybe
there should be a rate, S to P,
without the enzyme.
Although, I'm just
trying to tell you
about the rate of what
the enzyme is doing,
so you could write a
difference equation.
If I just let this model go to
infinity, then what happens?
AUDIENCE: You get P.
PROFESSOR: You get P.
And how much P is it?
A lot of P?
A little bit of P?
AUDIENCE: As much
as it can make.
PROFESSOR: It's all pee.
Right?
And how much substrate?
None, right?
So if I just let this go, you
have 0 substrate, all product.
Is that OK?
I mean is that, in
general-- I like product.
AUDIENCE: Time.
PROFESSOR: Time?
AUDIENCE: How much
time it would make too.
PROFESSOR: Well,
we can calculate
what the V is in this
model, and then we
could figure out what the time.
But there's something
wrong with that.
And normally I wouldn't
want to belabor the point,
but it's worth belaboring maybe.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
If we had a back reaction,
then that wouldn't happen.
PROFESSOR: Right,
OK, so this gets back
to your back reaction, right?
And I like the back rate.
It's just there was
something a little more
fundamental than the way you
phrased it, was my concern.
Because what you said is,
there might be some back rate.
Right?
And I guess what I would say
is that there's kind of always
some back rate, or that
the equilibrium-- this is
fundamental-- the equilibrium
ratio between S and P,
how does the enzyme change it?
AUDIENCE: Not at all.
PROFESSOR: It doesn't
change it, right?
So if you take the
enzyme, invertase,
and you put it in a
test tube with sucrose,
it's going to break down almost
all that sucrose, really fast.
It's going to speed things up
by a factor of 10 to the 5,
or I don't know, by a lot.
But if you leave the
test tube for a year,
it comes to an equilibrium
with the enzyme.
If you left it in the test
you without the enzyme
for a million years, you
would get to the same outcome.
You come to some equilibrium
between the substrate
and the product.
And that's a function
of the kinetics.
There's a delta G and so
forth, but the important point
is that the enzyme does not
change that equilibrium.
AUDIENCE: I just
have a question.
This molecule is
effectively [INAUDIBLE].
If you leave it in a test
tube for a million years,
then the ATP will
all be consumed.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But if
you keep providing
ATP, then you should--
PROFESSOR: Well, first of
all, not all enzymes actually
are coupled to ATP.
So ATP is a way of putting
out a big delta G, right?
So that you can really
push things far.
And ATP could, in principle,
be included as a co-factor,
and then you take the
overall delta G of that,
and then calculate it.
But if you want
to keep on adding,
then it complicates things.
But I think, for many enzymes,
it's more straightforward
just to think about
enzymes that don't require
any extra input of energy.
So they're just lowering
the energy barrier
and they're just speeding
up the rate of reaction.
But the important point
there is that they're
speeding up both rates.
So the equilibrium between those
two is not going to change.
And that's why, this
thing, it's a great model,
but like all models
you have to make
sure you keep track of what the
assumptions are going into it.
Because this is going to
violate the laws of physics
if you take this
model too seriously.
AUDIENCE: I don't understand
what the fundamental principle
that's being violated is.
Because why is it not that
if you have it stable,
everything is product.
You never see as in nature.
I mean, how is that not
a physical situation?
AUDIENCE 2: So if you can
get a really small test
tube with one G and one
S, isn't it just like--
PROFESSOR: But
the same statement
that we talked about
for single, then
you would want-- if you had
just a single substrate going
to product-- then you
want to look probably
at the time average.
Because, the thing is that
the equilibrium is determined
by the delta G of the reaction.
And that's going to determine
the equilibrium, whether you
have the enzyme there or not.
So if the delta G
is such that it's
at equilibrium--
sort of 90% product,
10% substrate-- then
what you can do is go,
well if you start out
with all substrate,
this model may work wonderfully.
But then as you're getting
closer to that equilibrium,
then this model's going
to be breaking down
because this model
is not accounting
for the back reaction,
as you were saying.
But I just want to stress that
it's not just a detailed model,
or it's not just a
failure for some enzymes,
this is the way
that enzymes work.
Are there other
questions about this?
Or different ways of
thinking about it?
So, it's not used up.
It speeds up reaction
in both directions.
AUDIENCE: I mean, but
that's not necessarily true.
You can have an
enzyme that is only
really capable of
going in one direction.
PROFESSOR: Really?
We should meet after class
and you can give me your--
AUDIENCE: It basically binds
in a particular direction.
PROFESSOR: It's
just not allowed.
So it's true that
enzymes can be--
and this is getting to the other
fundamental point of an enzyme,
which is that they,
especially enzymes in biology,
can be exquisitely specific.
What you're saying
is that it's really
only catalyzing this
one, weird reaction,
going from some funny substrate
to some funny product, right?
But that enzyme also speeds
up that back reaction,
going from the funny product
to the funny substrate.
And that's just like
the nature of the beast.
I'm try to think of what I can--
AUDIENCE: That's where you
have one enzyme going one way,
and another going the
other way in biology.
PROFESSOR: So it
does happen there,
but then what they
are often doing
is they're coupling things to
ATP hydrolysis or something,
in order to actually make that
reaction go in the single way.
Just as kind of like a general
statement-- because the way
these things work is that
there's some over here
and it's over here
somehow, and these enzymes,
they just lower
this energy barrier.
AUDIENCE: So the
thing that confused
me at first is that I was
just thinking of rates,
and I think the thing
that's important
is to just realize again that
the enzyme doesn't change
the thermodynamics, it
only changes that variable
to change where they are.
So the key thing
is that it doesn't
change the ratio of the
product through the substrate,
the rates are realatively--
PROFESSOR: Right, because from
a thermodynamic standpoint,
it's not used up, which
means there's an enzyme here
and an enzyme here.
So these final states,
you can think about only
in terms of the substrate
and the product,
because the enzyme was there
in both beginning and ending.
So from a thermodynamic
standpoint,
it's just you're not
allowed to change
one rate without the other.
Now in the reading, you saw
the Michaelis Menten kinetics,
where you found
that once you reach
this equilibrium between the
enzyme substrate complex,
the velocity can be
described by something
that is rather simple.
There's some Km plus S,
and then there's some Vmax.
And if the substrate
concentration,
the total concentration
is very large,
then you can just think
about this is the S total.
Now in this case,
this, once again,
can be thought of in this limit
of if the enzyme concentration
is really small, then this
is really just the fraction
of the enzyme that's bound.
So we've already spent
a lot of time thinking
about how to get at
the fraction bound,
and the question is, what
should this Km be here?
Now that I've told you that
it's the fraction bound,
is it just going to be the
same thing that we had before?
Is the Km the same
thing is the Kd?
So remember, before, we found
that Kd was just Kr over Kf.
But you should, in principle,
be able ti just look at that
and say what fraction
bound should be.
AUDIENCE: Is it Kr over Kf
plus-- other way around,
Kr plus Kcat over Kf
PROFESSOR: Yes, because
now, from the standpoint
of the enzyme, there's some rate
at which you form the complex.
And now the lifetime
of that complex
has been reduced,
because now there
are two ways for the complex
to fall apart, right?
One, is could just go
back where it came from,
but the other is that you
can catalyze the reaction.
So, from the standpoint of the
enzyme and the fraction bound,
then we can just--
the entire discussion
that we had before--
we can just replace Kd
with this new
Michaelis constant, Km.
Where now, we say now it's the
Kr up in the numerator still,
but now, instead of just
being Kf at the bottom,
we have to add Kcat,
because there are just
two ways that that
enzyme substrate
complex can fall apart.
Oh I'm sorry, I've
already messed up.
Kf over-- So Kcat
has to be with Kr.
So it just kind of speeds up the
effective rate of dissociation.
And of course, depending
whether Kcat is large or small
as compared to Kr, this can be
either a large or small effect.
But these rates, they just add.
And we'll spend a lot of time
thinking about how rates add
and so forth in a few weeks.
AUDIENCE: For this
expression to be valid,
don't you need Kcat to be much
longer than the other rates?
PROFESSOR: Right, yes.
So you want Kcat
to be-- So there's
various kinds of limits in which
you can talk about this thing.
So in general, what you
want is Kcat to be small,
and you also want the initial
transient to have gone away.
Because when you first
add the substrate,
you don't yet have any
enzyme substrate complex.
So you have to wait
until you've gotten
to this so-called steady state,
where the Michaelis Menten
formula applies.
And then you also
can't have let it
go too far, because
then of course you're
going to start running
out of substrate.
In the homework, you're
going to get a chance
to play with Michaelis
Menten kinetics a little bit,
and think about the
dynamics when you have
different kinds of inhibitors.
So you can imagine having
inhibitors that inhibit
multiple different ways.
You could have an inhibitor
the binds the enzyme,
and prevents the enzyme from
providing the substrate.
Now should this effect the Vmax?
We'll think about
it for 10 seconds
and we'll vote because
it's so much fun.
We have these cards.
Vmax change-- and this
is with an inhibitor
that binds here-- and forming
an EI complex, reversibly.
The question is,
does Vmax change?
A is yes and B is no.
I'll give you 10 seconds
to think about this.
So Vmax is, again, defined as
this rate of product formation
at saturation, when you
have a lot of the substrate.
Do you need time?
Or will time help?
Well who wants more time?
Just nod if you want more time.
OK, well let's see how we feel.
Let's go ahead and vote.
If I add this
competitive inhibitor,
the question is,
will be Vmax change?
Ready.
Three, two, one.
So we have a majority
of Bs, but some As.
Can somebody give the intuition
for why the Vmax should not
change?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Vmax is
when substrate is
far excess to the enzyme
and, at that time,
all of the enzymes bond to the
substrate not to the inhibitor.
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
So Vmax occurs when you have
lots and lots of substrate.
And, of course,
the condition you
have to be a little bit
careful, because it's not just
having more substrate
than the enzyme,
but it's when the
substrate is saturating.
So if you have lots
and lots of substrate,
then the important
point there is
that it's when you've
pushed this reaction all
the way over here, all
the enzyme is bound,
and that's when you get
this maximal rate of product
formation.
And that's true, you might
need more substrate in order
to get all that enzyme
bound, because you
have to pull the enzyme away
from this side reaction.
And, indeed, this
kind of inhibitor
alters the Km, the effect
of Km of the reaction.
But it does not
affect this Vmax,
whereas other inhibitors
can bind this complex
and prevent it from
catalyzing the reaction.
And that will instead affect
Vmax, but won't affect Km.
So this was a powerful
way that enzymologists
have used to try to get at
mechanism of inhibitors.
So if you have
some small molecule
you know somehow inhibits
some enzymatic reaction
and you want to know,
how is it doing that?
One thing you can do is you
can titrate in that inhibitor
and then measure
the Michaelis Menten
curve to get out the
Vmax and Km to try
to get a sense mechanism.
And I always say we should
be drawing these things.
So V is a function
of-- and this is
in the [? lit ?] for
a lot of substrate
relative to the enzyme--
then we can indeed
say it's going to plateau
in Vmax at concentration Km.
It's at 1/2.
And then it plateaus.
This is a very, very,
very common curve.
Lots of things in biology and
life start at 0 and plateau,
and there are almost only
two ways you can do that.
OK, there are more
than two ways,
but there are a very small
number of ways you can do that.
This is one of them.
Any questions on these Michaelis
and Menten kinetics inhibitors?
You're going to spend a couple
hours over the next few days
thinking about this.
So what I want to do
for the last 20 minutes
is switch gears a
little bit and to think
about the simple dynamics
of gene expression.
The ideas that we've
just been talking about
end up being just very relevant
for the simple models here.
So what we want to think
about is a situation where
we have some transcription
factor, X, that is activating
expression of gene Y. So we
have X activating Y. Now,
the way we can think
about this, for example,
is that we may have X,
which together with some
signal S of X, turns
into some X star
It's X star that can
bind to the promoter
and lead to expression of Y.
Now in Uri's book, he
talks about this idea
of a separation of
time scales that
is often useful to invoke when
thinking about gene expression.
In this context, what
was the fast event?
AUDIENCE: Activation of X?
PROFESSOR: Activation
of X. So in many cases,
if this is a sugar or a small
molecule that is going to be,
in this case, activating X, that
can occur really quite quickly.
Often maybe less than a second.
The rate-limiting step
would then, in many cases,
be getting the signal
into the cell, so
depending on how that works.
So this occurs very rapidly.
What that means is if
we look at a signal Sx,
as a function of time, where
it starts out being absent
and then, all of a sudden, sugar
appears in the environment,
we can think about the
concentration of X and X star
So X starts out high and then
quickly goes down, right?
Whereas X star will do the
reverse here, quickly comes up.
And this should be flat.
Now, what is it that Y will
do as a function of time?
So if X is an activator that
means that before X star became
available, there was
no expression of Y.
So it should be low.
So X is quickly activated,
turns into X star.
So we start expressing
Y. So, roughly,
what does this curve look like?
Somebody please help me.
AUDIENCE: It's S-shaped.
PROFESSOR: OK, so it
could be S-shaped.
The thing that's very
fast is activation of X,
and then what's really
still rather fast
is equilibration of X
star on this promoter.
So that might
still be very rapid
because these things were
nearly instantaneous, But.
Coming to equilibrium here
still might happen over
time scales of seconds.
So that means that you
actually, sort of quickly,
start getting expression,
at least on time scales
are relevant in terms of
hours kind of time scales.
Of course, it still does
take time to express.
So it takes minutes for the
RNA polymerase to transcribe,
and then of course
the ribosome's
going to have to do something.
What do I want to ask?
Let's write down the
equation that Uri
invokes because there's a
very real sense in which it
does, maybe, look a
little bit more S-like.
But at least in terms of
Uri's kind of formalism,
he often would say, the
change in the concentration
of this protein, it's going
to be some function of,
in this case X star.
And then there's another term
here, which was the minus alpha
Y. What was the
minus alpha Y due to?
AUDIENCE: Degradation.
PROFESSOR: Right, so
there are two terms.
So there's alpha, and it's going
to be the sum of two things.
There's alpha due
to degradation.
So if the protein is degraded
actively in some way.
If the protein is
not degraded, then
does that mean that
alpha is equal to 0?
No.
So what is this other term?
AUDIENCE: Cell growth.
PROFESSOR: Right, so it's
alpha due to some growth.
And cell growth leads
to some dilution effect.
So if you have the same
number of proteins in the cell
that the cell is
growing, that means
the concentration is shrinking.
Right?
Now the reality
of this process is
that it's complicated, because
cell growth is not uniform.
But if you kind of
average over things,
then a reasonable
description is just to say,
just a first order
effective dilution rate.
If you want to, you can write
down a more detailed formula,
or a model where, you say
if cell growth does this,
then-- It's going to kind
of wiggle a little bit
over the course
of the cell cycle,
but this is a
reasonable description.
Now what this is saying
is that even if there
is no active degradation,
then there still
is an effective term
due to this dilution.
And this means that if
we immediately activate,
and if F of X star-- at time
T equal to 0 here-- if it just
goes to some beta, then
what is the long time
solution of this equation?
AUDIENCE: Beta/alpha.
PROFESSOR: Beta/alpha, right?
So we know it should
eventually come to beta/alpha.
What's the characteristic time
scale for it to get there?
AUDIENCE: Cell alpha's
rate, it's 1/alpha.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So characteristic
time is 1/alpha.
The solution to this
differential equation
is just an exponential where,
if extend this line here,
this is 1/alpha.
So that's time.
And then, of course,
the T 1/2, the time
it takes to get to 1/2, is
indeed different by log 2,
and that's the
cell division time.
This point here-- this is
at T 1/2-- is cell division.
This is for a stable protein,
assuming that alpha degradation
is equal to 0.
So the thing to remember is
that this basic differential
equation of Y dot is equal
to a minus alpha Y, is
an exponential by going to 0.
Whereas if you have a
constant term here, then
it's an exponential going
to some nonzero value.
So, indeed, if the
signal here goes away,
then we quickly come back here.
So this comes here.
This comes here, and then this--
does it go back down to 0?
Is it more or less
rapid returning to 0
than it took to come up?
All right.
OK.
So, how can I phrase this?
OK, faster decay, question mark.
A is yes, and B is
no, and you can always
do C or something if you
don't know what I'm asking.
The question is, we've
turned off the signal,
is it going to go away faster,
or slower, or the same?
This is faster.
B can even be slower maybe.
C is same.
Do you understand
the options now?
So we stopped expressing
Y, so concentration of X
is going to decrease, right?
Question is, it is going
to go away faster, slower,
or the same as the
rate that it came up?
Do you need more time?
Ready.
Three, two, one.
OK so we have a fair
agreement that, this thing,
it's going to be the same.
So there's a characteristic
time for it to come
and it's the same characteristic
time for it to degrade away.
So this, I would say,
is not a priori obvious,
but it's really just
the nature of when you
have these sorts of situations.
This sets the time
scale for if you
want to change the
concentration-- doesn't matter
whether you're going
to 0, a finite number,
or if you go from high
to low, but not 0.
Again, it's going to be
exponential in the same time
scale.
So if you want
that to be faster,
if you want to be able
to respond more rapidly,
then one solution would be to
actively degrade the protein.
Right?
Now it's obvious that
degrading the protein actively
will allow it to go
way more rapidly.
What's perhaps less
obvious is that there's
a real sense in which
degrading the protein allows
this response to be
more rapid as well.
But of course, did we
keep everything constant?
If I say, oh I want the
curve to look like this,
can I just increase
the degradation rate?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well let's say
that X star is already maximal
saturating.
So we're already-- well, OK.
So I understand.
OK, now I understand
what you're saying.
You need to increase beta,
and that could either
be by increasing
X star or it could
be just by increasing the
strength of that promoter.
So the idea is that if you
want a more rapid on or off,
you can also increase
the degradation rate.
But there's a cost
to that, which
is that you have to
make more protein.
And, indeed, many transcription
factors are actively degraded.
And that may be because if you
are using these transcription
factors to turn
things on and off,
then you want to
get rapid responses.
And, also, transcription
factors are often not
expressed at the same high
levels as structural proteins.
So that means that the
cost of degrading them
is not going to be as severe.
If you're actively degrading
cell wall type of things,
that's going to
be really costly.
Are there any
questions of what I
mean by this discussion
of active degradation,
why it might help, costs?
Because, over the
next week or two,
we're going to see
multiple possible solutions
to this problem.
If you want to increase
the rate that you respond
to some environmental
change, one way you can do it
is by actively degrading some
of the signaling proteins.
But there are other solutions
we're going to come up with,
such as auto regulation.
In the last few
minutes here, I wanted
to say something about this
question of ultrasensitivity.
So there are many
cases where you
would like to get very
sensitive responses, i.e.
you'd like to be able
to make a modest change
in the concentration of some,
for example, transcription
factor, and get a significant
change in-- I don't know why
I erased that but--
and you want to be
able to get a significant
change in the output.
And one way that
you can do this is
by having some sort of
cooperative binding.
If you have dimerization
of a transcription factor
before binding then
you, for example,
can get a more
sensitive response.
So one way to think that this
is if you have an X activating Y
right in this simple
case, then the rate
of Y expression
as a function of--
and here we're going
to write X for now
and we'll just assume that
all Xs are indeed active.
OK?
Now if it just is a
single X binding Y,
then this should behave just
like this Michaelis Menten
formula, where there's some
maximal rate of expression
here.
There's going to be some Kd,
which is bound 1/2 the time,
and then some curve
that looks like this.
So this would be an
example of something
that is not ultrasensitive
and that you
don't get a significant change
in the rate of Y expression--
or the equilibrium Y
value, if you'd like--
as a function of changing X.
As you start having
more and more X,
you would need get
more and more Y,
but that ratio, if you
double X, you always
get less than a doubling
of Y. So the question is,
what can you do to make
things somehow more sensitive?
You'd like something that
looks a little bit more--
well the ultimate would
be 0 and then beta.
And indeed this would be
this logic kind of limit.
So this is Y expression
as a function of X.
If you didn't get any until some
Kd and then all of a sudden you
had beta, that would be
as sensitive as you could
possibly-- this is
ultra-, ultra- sensitive.
So there's one solution that
was talked about in the book
to get something that's a
little bit more like this.
AUDIENCE: Cooperative binding.
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
cooperative binding.
So we often describe
these functions--
this is the rate of expression
as a function of X--
as via some hill equation.
So I'm just going
to write Xs here.
So it could be there's
X, K plus X here.
Now if you have
cooperative binding
either at the side of the
promoter or dimerization,
trimerzation, something
before binding,
you can get some effective
hill coverage in here,
where this is going to be
up X to the n, X to the n, K
to then.
We put K to n here just so
that all the units are still
reasonable.
And as n increases, this thing
becomes more and more sensitive
or ultrasensitive.
So this is with n
just equal to 1,
just a monomer binding
in a simple way.
Kd is still the 1/2 mark.
So things always cross
here, but if it's 2
then it might look like
this, now three, four.
So it gets steeper and steeper
as that hill coefficient
increases.
As Uri mentions, for many input
in many genes, if you go in
and you measure these
things, you often
get something that's reasonably
well-defined by the S
with a n somewhere
between 1 and 4.
So things are often
moderately cooperative.
Maybe I'll just tell you
about this other mechanism
for ultrasensitivity, this
idea of molecular titration.
I'm going to leave you with the
basic model, or the basic idea,
and then at the beginning
of class on Thursday,
we will try to
figure out what are
the requirements for the
various binding affinities
in order for that model to work.
So what's neat
about this is it's
a situation where
you can get something
that is ultrasensitive
without any cooperativity.
The idea is that you have
some X that is indeed
binding to the promoter to
activate expression of Y,
but, in addition, you have
some other protein, say W,
that can bind to X and turn
it into this complex XW.
So we can always describe
things as there's some Kw here,
some Kd for X to
bind to the promoter,
and for some relations
of Kw, Kd, and W
total, you can get
ultrasensitivity.
What happens is that if you look
at this rate of expression--
so this is Y expression--
as a function of X,
if you don't have any W here,
then indeed it just looks
like our standard thing here.
Whereas in the this
is when you add W,
when you add this molecular
titration phenomenon,
you can make this curve
slide over so you don't
get significant
expression until X--
or this is X total
if you'd like--
is larger than W total and this
whole curve just slides over.
You can see this
is ultrasensitive.
So nothing happens until
all of a sudden you
start getting expression.
So what we're going to do
is on the beginning of class
on Thursday, we'll
try to figure out
what is the relationship
between these different binding
parameters in order to get
something that looks like this.
Are there any questions
about anything
that we've said so far today?
With that, why don't
we go ahead and quit.